ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
premier nus ainsi que le studio daniel
et diana haddad même qu'il manque avec
moi
un animateur de talent benjamin castaldi
mais son legs de tpm p la chroniqueuse
la moins chère
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un à qui on comprend à moitié ses
phrases j'ai en michel vers le bas et
ces années où on m'attend métal ou norig
abribus et j'ai dit non c'est moi
wattignies c'était la ghréline vas-y mon
chéri maxime dillies
aucune et amoureuse de lui mais moi à
cet enjeu plus amoureuse que toi gérad
émaillé la punition de tpm
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis donc bah je présente les
misseriya non je fais quoi moi tu
m'avais dit quand tout va partir en
retraite je vais prendre ta place
je fais la présentation pas non mais la
dirisi l'asie sont matthieu delormeau
vas-y wi max de larmor il rêve de
présenter une émission sur ces 8 mais
tout le monde a envie qu'il soit ce
billet
[Applaudissements]
la plus drôle finalement un immense
qu'ils le puissent porter plainte et
gmail chez les dames ans oui ça va
étuver soirée donc une émission 100
merlus tel big star avec moi oui t'as
kiffé oui à des talents de dengue te
ment pas présenté cet anneau qu'on
apprécie mon chéri d'avoir été si je
t'aime trop
[Applaudissements]
fort bien je regarde on vient nous voir
je reviens noir tu va les faire un petit
bisou accueilli oui merci merci au jury
d'avoir été bien tenu et qui avec avec
ma tata et ma maman je suis fais là
[Applaudissements]
merci mon chéri d'amour katembo la
planificatrice
[Applaudissements]